there are increasing signs the three
police forces in the Madeleine McCann
case are squabbling over who knew what
and when what they've done and not done
to solve the mystery in Lisbon the
McCanns Portuguese lawyer said he's
watching with concern this is not the
Champions League between police
departments the fact that the police is
saying something the Portuguese police
is claiming again the British police and
vice-versa
that will not take us anywhere I think
we are wasting time and we are spreading
energy instead of cooperating that's
what I hope and the family hope that can
be done it'd be a much more a stronger
investigation is everybody is pushing
the same side a big dispute why has it
taken 13 years to treat German sex
offender Christian B as the prime
suspect at the time Madeleine vanished
he was living in the Algarve he's
thought to have been close to the
apartment where she was sleeping here e
registered his car in a new name the
next day
seven years later when Scotland Yard
officers dug for evidence they had
already discounted the German suspect
according to Portuguese police the TJ
the Deputy Director here claims his
staff a Scotland Yard Christian B's name
as long ago as 2012 it was on a list of
hundreds of potential suspects handed
over at the time but according to the
Portuguese police chief the British
detectives thought Christian B wasn't
relevant to their investigation and the
three police forces can't seem to agree
if Madeleine is alive or dead do you
think the German prosecutor should tell
them a Cannes what he knows if he thinks
Madeline's dead they remain the father
and the mother they are more than anyone
they want to know what happened it are
entitled they have the right to know
what happened and with priority
especially when we are arguing that
their daughter is dead and another
dispute the German authorities insist if
they charge the suspect he will be tried
in Germany the McCanns lawyer said he
push for a trial in Portugal Martin
Brant Sky News in Lisbon